pour me faire venir dans cette émission
tpm people il en est hors de question
oui oui la semaine dernière véronique
genest me traiter de connard cette
semaine c'est encore vu vincent mcdoom
aussi cette semaine c'est encore une
charmante personne qui ne peut pas me
saquer où nous sac et ses deux petits
s'agit-il
manoir bois vert thierry ardisson non
sébastien folin non mais non pourquoi
lui il aime tout le monde ça passait
infoline en effet la météo
hommes femmes c'est une femme femme
avait quitté fâché n'ont même pas vu des
horreurs n'ont même pas aller avoue as
tu géré même pas rien à [ __ ] en fait
ah bah voilà les marchands n'ont pas dit
non avant delphine alors on s'approche
absolument série ce mythe est liée non
non et non il me semble en fait non
elissa
maintenant alors je ne réponds jamais si
sonia rolland c'est blâme à cette heure
là maya marche à best buy lama baird a
pour ça alors sept jardins de regarder
ce qu'elle a dit ah bon tout va bien
touche pas à mon poste oui et matthieu
delormeau qu'est ce qui se passe avec
lui il a attaqué par mois il a dit que
j'étais ennemis saveuse il y là et
déblatérer pas mal de choses vraiment
sale je m'en fiche par contre quand
quand ma mère a pleuré à cause de ça
quand beaucoup de personnes se sont
senties salle à cause de ça j'ai trouvé
ça vraiment très petit très déplacé
quand on m'invite par la suite en disant
mais matthieu delormeau il vous adore
s'il m'adorait ils ont les jamais dit ça
pour me faire venir à cette émission là
il est hors de question nous la
prochaine fois qu'on doit recevoir ce
sera la première fois qu'on va se
rencontrer et on aura des choses à se
dire hors caméra donc mathieu je
t'invite à prendre contact avec moi pour
qu'on puisse échanger à ce sujet
et vous seriez très drôle c'est que ce
qui est vrai c'est que c'est déborah
capelle pour la programmation et à sa
voix qu'elle appelle à une personne a
dit
mathieu vous s'adorent à chaque fois je
connais pas la personne c'est bien ça
n'a pas marché la véritable histoire
mais non mais la verrie cela mais la
véritable histoire je la connais vous
l'aimez regret un véritable histoire
c'est qu'elle vous a fait des avances si
vous avez refusé non
exactement c'est pas faux pas c'est que
sur le plateau de thé pmp vous aviez dit
que c'était une nice à buzz oif de bien
méchant ta mère a pleuré vous n'avez
surtout que vous avez la mémoire
compères cours du congrès la mémoire
bébé que la mémoire et de toutes les
deux de toutes les miss de toutes les
miss qu'on a connus ces dernières années
elle a fait quand même la plus
susceptible
on sent que voilà les mines jour un peu
dans l'agressivité même
si j'ai blessé ça ma mort mais je rends
nexus est visible n'est pas le nude et
les mutilés des ce que j'ai dit sur elle
ou mal des gens aux siens et après à la
division venez avec moi elle aussi j'ai
pas déjeuné avec tous les gens que
j'écrive comme la langue et j'ai bientôt
à placer sur ce coup je bien défriché le
terrain bah c'est gentil elle a
rencontré ou à la porte 1 quand même
mais c'est très gentil de monsieur
apparu qu'effectivement le positionner
goss
de regards qui sera le prochain alors
c'est quoi ce qui parole c'est que on a
on a des ennemis à la hauteur de sa
carrière je suis bien comme
quelque chose véronique genest madrange
on a quand même donné j'aurais préféré
qu'il est fils ken croteau tu vas en
frais ou des gens qui n'ont mangé sa
commune jean michel a soumis la faute de
grammaire et c'est vrai faut arrêter de
dire il en est hors de question ou c
hors de question où il n'en est pas
question mais on me lance pas les deux
je faire si m capella mais là c'est la
maîtresse d'école qui se serait de matri
capello cave non je suis un singulier
l'armée sur une cible un peu crado c'est
ainsi que le mou rentrer dans le
nourrain